- You always just have to be somebody
who really loves what you're doing
and make an affordable step.
Dedicate a certain amount
of time to the business.
Two hours a week, four hours a week,
50 hours a week, no matter what.
A lot of times I want to think
what am I promising the consumer?
When the needle is finally in the vein
and you're really hooked,
it's like being in love.
I have this little gamble theory,
if nobody else likes
it, it might be a hit.
Can't dribble a basketball,
can't sing, can't draw,
didn't know anybody, didn't go to college,
that didn't stop me at all.
I need a job!
Really good designer,
I will make you money.
- He's an American entrepreneur,
investor, TV personality,
author, and motivational speaker.
He's best known as the founder,
president and CEO of FUBU.
He appears as an investor
on the ABC reality TV show Shark Tank.
He's Daymond John, and here is my take
on his Top 10 rules for success.
Rule number four is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus footage.
- And the thing that all
entrepreneurs have in common
is every entrepreneur makes
an affordable step forward,
no matter what direction it is,
then they learn from
that and they repeat it.
That means that when you're
in the dark, you can't see,
you make a small step, you
feel around, you keep going,
or you step back because
you stepped on something.
And that's the first one, two,
three, four years of business
entrepreneurs make the affordable step.
The other people who are not entrepreneurs
who are doing it for money make
sometimes unfortunate steps.
They go and they say I need
to get a million dollars
cause that's going to cure the problem.
Now you've got a million dollar problem.
Or they make bad steps because
they want to go get money because
they just want to go get
money, they want the Benz
and all of a sudden they
end up in a place that
they don't want to be or sometimes
they end up not existing at all.
So, you always just have to be
somebody who really
loves what you're doing
and make and affordable step forward
and learn and then repeat.
Dedicate a certain amount
of time to the business.
Two hours a week, four hours a week,
50 hours a week, no matter what,
it starts to compound after year one,
after year two, after year three.
If you dedicated two hours a week to
this new hobby or love or
business, at the end of the
year it's over 100 hours put in.
Don't be in a rush, first of all.
Learn all the mistakes early.
And then, have some kind of strategy.
Know that this is where you want to be
after year one, two, three, four, and five
and you have to be really
honest with yourself.
Is the business worth it?
Is it costing too much?
At the end of the day a lot of times
people think inwardly about
their company or their product.
A lot of times I want to think
What am I promising the consumer?
And how will I deliver that promise?
I have to think about what's in it for
that end of the day person who's going to
come out of their pocket and buy it,
so what am I promising, how
am I going to deliver it,
and now, do I have the assets
to deliver it accurately?
What changed in my life wasn't
the fact that I wanted
to become a millionaire.
What changed in my life was the fact that
I wanted to make these clothes for myself,
for other people, because
nobody respected the smart kid.
I was doing something I loved
and then all of a sudden
it started to take off.
- [Man] Can you tell me a little bit about
once that passion finally caught on,
and you finally decided this is something
that I want to move forward with.
And a little bit about that first product,
and how it all took off from there.
And then did you ever
decide at that point,
there was no slowing you down?
- When that passion, when
that thing grabs ahold of you,
and as they say when the
needle is finally in the vein,
and you're really hooked,
it's like being in love.
It's like you thought you
liked somebody when you were
13, 14 years old and that was just
something new and it was puppy love.
But when you're 22, 23 years old
and you're out there sitting there
making life decisions and saying
I could see myself with this
person for the rest of my life,
and you're getting butterflies
every time you see them,
that's what it is when you have a business
and you have a company that you love,
you can't see anything else.
And I would've dressed people
til today, for free if I could
and I'm sure you hear
that from everybody else,
an artist will rap and sing
anytime they can be seen,
and just like the kids in school
who always got kicked out in
Special Ed who were comedians,
they can't help it, they know
that that's the biggest bully
in the schoolyard and they can't help it,
but crack a joke even
though they're going to get
their head cracked open,
but they just love what they're doing.
And that's just how it was as a business.
I fell in love with FUBU
when I saw that first person
walking down the street
with my product on.
Many entrepreneurs fail
due to over funding,
so you look, we're in
a beautiful location,
Trattoria Il Mulino,
it's a legendary family
in the restaurant business,
and they've been doing this for years.
But look at somebody that
decides that they can cook
and they want to work on grandma's recipe.
They'll go out and they'll
get a $100,000 loan,
they'll open up a restaurant,
they have no experience doing that,
they'll have a beautiful
place, great staff,
but they didn't sell not one piece of food
in their entire life, and
they didn't understand
the operation of the business.
Eight months in, a year in,
when they realize why they
don't have any customers
because they didn't have a
customer base in the beginning,
they have a $100,000
loan now on the business,
and they haven't figured out the business.
Then all of a sudden
they have to close down.
I started off literally
with $800 worth of hats,
and that was the beginning.
- Take inventory of yourself.
That sounds very kum ba yah.
- It is but you know what, it's very hard.
You have to sit there and say
where am I good, where do I have assets
and where do I have liabilities?
Who do I know that can help me with this?
First of all, how much time will I have,
how much money will I have
to dedicate towards this?
What am I good at?
What do I hate and who
will I have to hire?
You know, a mom does that all day.
She looks at what we have to cook,
she looks at what time do we have
to get the kids to school, get them home,
when I have my own time with
my husband or everything else,
you have to take inventory of yourself
or you don't know what you have.
I think that there's four
levels that any brand
or product can go through.
They won't all hit the four levels,
so you can have an item, and that item is
alright, I'm making bottled water.
And water can be getting anywhere
from the fountain, to the stream
or you put it in a bottle.
You can then have a label,
you put any label on there
because you go into the store and you say
well that's bottled water,
I don't know the label's name, persay.
Then you have more of a brand.
Dasani. It's a brand, we
don't know much about it,
but then you can become a lifestyle.
Evian. Vitamin Water.
So, a lot of us don't get
to the level of lifestyle
where if you copy a piece of paper,
somebody might say go Xerox it,
when really, Xerox is a company.
Or you ask for a soda and
somebody calls it a Coke.
Where it basically categorizes everything.
You search for something
and they say "Google it,"
no matter how you're searching
and that becomes a lifestyle.
It's a challenge to go
through those processes
and what I do with all my companies is
I say to them that the easiest thing
to sell in the world is the truth.
Back in the days it was
make it they will come,
and we can put some lipstick
on a pig and dress it up.
With this world of transparency today
you can create the biggest
lie campaign that you like
but one person at your office
is going to send out a tweet
and say it's all garbage and you're over.
So, if you understand that the
easiest thing to sell is the
truth and you know your DNA,
if you put that out there then people will
understand it and people will respect it.
Or at least if you lose, you know they
just weren't feeling you
but you know what it was.
I have a gut feeling that
this may be very, very good business
but it's not something that
I can go to sleep at night,
then it's not even a question,
I won't do it, number one.
Number two is the risk assessment is
a lot of times, I have
this little gamble theory,
if nobody else likes
it, it might be a hit.
If it's not a lot of money or time,
I'm going to take a gamble
on it because usually you get
the lowest common denominator
if everybody agrees.
The people that I see
utilize "The Power of Broke"
more than anybody at
all are the people that,
when they reach a level of
success, they still use it
and that's how they
maintain their success,
that hunger and drive.
And we grew up at a time
and age where it was
you need money to make money,
you got to know somebody.
Well, look at me, look at half this room.
I grew up African American, short,
dyslexic, got left back one time,
almost got left back a second time,
can't dribble a basketball,
can't sing, can't draw,
didn't know anybody, didn't go to college,
that didn't stop me at all.
- Yeah.
- I had a mother that
really loved me dearly,
and I had some like-minded
FUBU partners and friends
who would never let me stop
and I never let them stop.
And I had a will and a drive
and I still have all those same things,
I still rise and grind
every single morning.
(techno music)
Alright, so I'm here at Mercedes.
I did an opening of one of my lines
the other day right in that building
and I got mobbed walking out here,
but today I decided to
get extra fashionable.
I need a job. Really good designer.
I will make you money.
(techno music)
Who can take a picture of us?
- [Woman] You just got it?
- I just got it!
You see how he gave me a shot?
He knows me from work so I kept asking
and then he said I'll do it for you.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Gishka asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I also love to know
which of Daymond John's
Top 10 Rules had the biggest impact,
which one resonated with you the most.
Leave it in the comments and
I will join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching,
continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.
- How do you pick the people
that you want to align with?
- We have to be on the same page,
somebody like Pitbull, when Pit and I sit,
I learn just as much from
him as he does from me.
I know that he is a
fluid person, a thinker,
a strategist, and I work
with several other people
like CeeLo and Little
John and Vanessa Simmons,
a lot of these people we
have to be on the same page
because a lot of these guys,
they're like on the first date
they tell you they want
to change the world,
then all of a sudden they're
late to the meetings,
they don't show up, they're
going and drinking champagne,
they're just doing it for showtime.
But, when I see somebody that I like
and I love to work with,
I'm happy and I know
that we have a strategy
and we're going to do the
best we're going to do.
Start selling, you see the
best focus group in the world
is people who buy things.
You can give everything
you want to grandma,
everybody else, everybody's
going to tell you
your baby's beautiful.
Until you go out there and sell
or until you go out there and
share this concept with others
you don't know if you
have something of value.
When I say sell something,
it doesn't mean always money.
Get a thousand likes on Facebook.
Sell to a local promoter
in the area, a TV show
or a magazine and say we
want to talk about this.
People just always think about it
oh I should've, would've, could've,
and they just go out and sell.
I started with $40 worth
of hats, that was it.
And I just sold, and sold, and sold,
and some of them got thrown back at me,
and then I improved it, and improved it,
and I sold it to them again.
So you just have to go out and sell
and you have to start today.
I need to make sure that everybody knows
success is not money.
Money drives you up to your
problems in a limousine.
So success is sometimes
being a great parent,
dedicating yourself to your faith.
There are so many people
that don't necessarily have
millions and millions of dollars
and they're happier than
many of us ever will be.
- Yeah
- So I don't want to over
push the fact of money
as success cause that's not the case.